blog mas numero 19 ormai i miei capelli
non c'è più scampo
non sono venuto a fano vicino a gabriele
che si è comprato un hotel
vediamo che ha combinato permesso o
bella vita è contro tutti accomodati
pure qui vicino al cugino ne sa cosa è
stata la chiave in questi giorni un
prato tutto problema dentro avevamo
comprato 11 paia di scarpe questa
settimana 4 pantaloni uguali di stesso
modello come ti senti mai cambiato nulla
è solo riempito un vuoto importante
morane la regola del compro tutto guarda
guarda lì siamo pieni di buste possiamo
fare dei regali con la bottiglia di
spumante ma questo è tutto a posto per
il video
va bene passammo dagli altri e compro
che saranno tornati da milan ormai dai
andiamo rimontare sono tutti i regali
che abbiamo fatto ma di riandare mangimi
vicini ma che schifo però è amaro coda
invece ce l'hai la samb una gomma che di
bidoni di tamburi ma io so da gas e 654
costanza violo sempre sambuca tabulare
comunque sono le 12 30
tutta una parte ragazzi compro tutto per
tutto
mi ha chiesto la stanza stanza
albergo o un prodotto
sei tornato cosa volevo non conosci la
legge del contro tutto ci vediamo a casa
andiamo a casa
ma adesso ho detto l'ho introdotto nel
contro tutto nella tecnica del compro
tutto come ti senti come prima
totalmente vuoto esatto una tecnica che
ti appaga nel milan è a mente per
ritorni al mese di solitudini molto
stato di solitudine e sbagliato comprare
materialità arricchite sempre voi stesse
rock e cosa facciamo noi piaceva l'idea
la regaliamo gli altri facendo crede che
sono regali per loro però montebello e
con quel momento del confronto è stata i
numeri lo devo dire che mi sono sentito
potente per quegli attimi per adesso
guardando questa busta neanche mi
ricordo male sto vedendo adesso certo
scoprendo adesso quello che abbiamo
comprato le ragioniamo li ragazzi legali
per voi mi ha guardato di ricavi che
tutti dei balocchi di giocando abbiamo
comprato questo arrivo regalo abbiamo un
barboncino ecco questo e per molto il
bacino di un bacino ragazzi c'è tanta
roba vogliamo andare avanti
un diario che diventa maggio e fermare
[Applauso]
il mestolo toccato bracciate la lui ma
credo lei sono molto mostro un assassino
[Musica]
rosso percorsa nel giusto e ci vuole
ragazzi e chi vuole l'ok alla poppa la
barca fanta andare io per adesso
pubblicato solo palle non avete mai
conosciuto il padre la madre
avete visto morire la madre il padre e
madre di mamme
un cervo in plastica niente l'occhiale
chiaramente una certo la acquisti mente
sono stati ben più un lecca lecca lo
giro a casa occhiale con doppia
stanghetta per arrivare in porta regalo
ma anche infilare il membro se vuoi che
poi chiude davanti porta regalo di erbe
e ribadito la guardi sono questi
l'ottobre di per me 12 euro e di file o
la mia che già la mia preferita un
paniere vinay amore per tutte le
stagioni
questa tutto bello gigante
ma dove cazzo di lamone bravo e
telefonate va dunque raga complimenti
per la sincronia poi ve l'eravate
studiato c'era una grandissima
preparazione sino sensi colore talento
talento hangar volete dire qualcosa
in realtà avevo dei regali ma adesso
questo non era un naso
[Musica]
[Risate]
ed è proprio finisce dunque valico
antipodi che i regali berlina insomma
più coraggio vita cioè dopo questa
sciami sono una ciofeca
vi prego tra l'altro il regalo che
impediva le va bene vado a prendermi
regali si sente non ci credo cosa sono
quelle cose
ma che cos'è
io ho detto vale che volevo cambiare gli
orecchini e che volevo una roba in oro
giallo e non sono orecchini vero ma se
non mi dicevi prima la prima è saputo
ma chi ha punito regalino regalato gli
orecchini che cos'è questa roba
la privacy non ci credo che è ci sono
tutti a enrico zoom maggio leggo con
sopra scritto e un cagnolino non ci
credo che guarda quanta stupenda non ci
credo regali allora con caccia è stato
un bel problema
sì ho dovuto invertire una cosa perché
non c'era la parte attaccante
secondo il mio ma la coppa perché con la
coppa perché lo deve fare vincente ogni
tiro ma tu sei la pizza con scritto
gabriele e lo guardano doppia faccia più
emozioni ragazzi racconta sono identico
questa deriva dai capelli e quindi ho
dovuto rubare i capelli di harry potter
dal mio calendario dell'avvento che
grazie a dio sono tutte quelle cose
creato un botto con questo personaggio
e c'è pure scampato c'è scritto con
l'acqua sulle cose di cui 90 ma geniale
va bene ti riprendo io parli ragazzi il
mio male male
ragazzi gran regalo grande carica 91
come anche mia ho trovato una maglia che
identica il mio piccolo ma del mio
peggio ma molto si sa mai veramente sono
bellissimi ma è una gran giornata questo
tranne per il povero padre di bambine
bellissimo grazie vale cioè con simone
caldo membri ma abbiamo sentito parlare
ma c'è una salsa piccante e si chiama
ragazzi
chissà che il grado di piccantezza avrà
questa sala è gabriele quanto piccole
tema natale di merda concorrenza
non male ma devo dire che
l'imbottigliamento è bello
immagino che mangi st salsa fa il bagno
ragazzi c'è alcuno in fiamme chi è la
colpa
deve avere io dico sempre ma non ha
lavorato poi io parlo ancora capito come
se una comparativa avete presente il
guerriero che i personaggi erano alti
come montani valentina al titano
riguarda così ti senti che treno titano
ma una domanda che oggi non sarei più a
kabanga fare il titano ad oggi noi
abbiamo consumato solo quello
si mangia tutti i giorni con la kabanga
e il consumo è quello che sono poche
gocce che uno mette sono poche gocce di
mozione della congiura 20 dal treno e
stabilità e al direttivo una bassa del
pomodoro chiaramente in la tuta blu
metaman capito quella che se ho capito
perfettamente che dovremmo fare un
paragone presto non c'è paragone
apprezzare can do io non l'avrei aperto
così lo riciclato visto che tutti avete
fatto e lo farà un regalo o no questo no
che cos'è che cosa abbiamo che cosa
perché se c'è una cosa speciale
gli studenti conosco so come si è fatto
gli anni qui no non credete ce ne sono
due
enrico avevano scritto questi si è per
te ce ne sono per me ce ne stanno pure
in realtà accelerato un altro mara per
l'amica messa a 200 300 colline si
sentono l amore e scusa ma vediamo a
cosa dire che vendo di aver preso natale
a burri e l'ignoranza
se c'era qualche cosa di strano il mio
regalo ma come mai a conoscermi così
bene mi sono scervellato su ognuno di
voi che cazzo mi faccio trovare dentro
come per conoscere così bene i nostri
gusti mode e bollette ha giocato che ai
piani ha presentato al me che hai detto
compro tutto compra tutto è la tizia mi
guarda un certo punto si riuniscono
tutto il fano possiamo farcela domanda
ma facendo un festino però tutti hanno
fatto di regali volevo trovare anch'io
colletto e ne ho presi 200 perché sapevo
che uno e mezzogiorno nella fatturazione
tardi ma ogni 10.000 like sono 100
poletti in più quindi la prossima sfida
sarà 200 bimbi serviamo a 10mila sono
320 mila sono 400 bella ma mi fate
magnate riprendere d'ogni piacevole
quanto partito questa cosa non ho mai
finito lì ancora devo iniziare premi ma
non in tribunale bravi di fans che stai
a dub a chi è mancano 3 40 io ho
cominciato secondo burton in un tempo
record coronario sul mio primo pacco
quella viene mai arrivare i due intanto
25 ma questo è il mio secondo pacco ma
era stato un po intaccato credo perché a
seconda di quanti se ne possono andare
con l'aggressione mente stampate con la
sgrassi aver doppiato posso cos'è una
sgrassi nella coca cola grassi era penso
tre pacchetti posso mangiare tre fatti
pure 8
no io muoio pure ho mangiato dalle fan
della colpa ne ho io pure corretti
ciocco
uova bacon crostate e mangiato tutto
però grazie quindi regalo quindi è stato
un buon nata tas acquisterà inquadra il
viso mangiare bene
portatela mila medici prenderò io adesso
devo lavorare dopo massimo ranieri in
effetti gianmarco responsabile ci potete
giocare ragazzi un attimo
bravo no ok la lastra ieri gianni a
rimborsare devo riprendere la persona
giusta di tutta la casa ma dai
pepe pregio ragazzi che in
collaborazione con sony vi ha fatto
arrivare in dual boot buon senso ragazzi
so che in cui dovrebbero avere una la b
contro a casa santini a noi pugnalo come
impugnato lo sento sento e penso che sia
di una sensibilità tiriamo fuori bolide
ho paura e come se fosse mia figlia è
così rimasto ammirando le gambe solide
bolide ma quante viveva in legame
stupenda sony questo è l'inizio di una
serie di gameplay da gennaio partiamo
four preparatevi 9 voglio piangere
voglio ringraziare anch'io sony perché
me li sono tolti dalle scatole per
sempre così vado nave deviato e stava in
piedi a cassino ragazzi potevamo non
avere anche un regalo per loro almeno
vedere per l'occasione anche per te
allora lynch ha mandato la valle di
cosette per tutti quanti loro è una cosa
importante che in realtà mi sta passando
un attività di beneficenza molto
importante per salvare i cuccioli vi
lasciamo il link qua sotto per
informarli e per aderire eventualmente
alla cosa che si chiama lasciato la
società che carini per carini a quelli
culto smettila di distruggere un
possibile
stiamo parlando di animale ma anche però
di vegetali perché non crescere meglio
c'era scritto che doveva appoggiarlo e
non seppellirlo ristagna l'acqua ma è
troppo tardi ormai
puoi trovarci questa giornata è stata
un'emozione dopo l'altra e regalano i
regali su regali da parte nostra da
parte dei playstation carpe di royal
canin veramente pieni d'amore ci sono
arrivate anche le altre cose che per cui
dobbiamo ringraziare grazie davvero
grazie grazie grazie ci vediamo domani
ma io so già chi li ho persi con la play
li ho persi fatemi sapere se un domani
volete che faccio un gameplay qui su
youtube come dei pazzi